machine learning has fundamentally
changed how we solve problems
and the demand for engineers and data
scientists that can create machine
learning products has skyrocketed
to realize the full value of machine
learning applications software engineers
designers
product managers and data scientists
must work together
at all stages of development to bring
their models
into production and find meaningful
answers to difficult questions
by combining best practices from
software engineering and data science
machine learning devops engineers are
bridging the gap between theory and
implementation
ensuring that models consistently move
beyond training and
into production that is why udacity has
built the machine learning devops
engineer nanodegree program
with leading industry partners to help
you become in demand as a machine
learning devops engineer
this program's world-class curriculum
will teach you the skills you need to
collaborate with
a team in development implement
production-ready ml models outside of
cloud-based environments
and ultimately produce dependable and
scalable results that bring value
to your organization in addition you'll
learn how to engineer automated data
workflows
within a ci cd pipeline perform
continuous training and model validation
and track performance and ensure your
model stand the test of time
as machine learning evolves and becomes
more complex and even more essential
the skills taught in udacity's machine
learning devops engineer nanodegree
program
will help you stay in demand enroll in
udacity's machine learning devops
engineer nanodegree program
[Music]
today